i live in an incredibly undulating place
it's basically a series of hills and
valleys that continuously go on for
miles and miles miles so i thought i'd
take the opportunity today to go through
an incredible sloping site design with
you guys on arcade 25.
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about a steep
undulating sight that basically drops
off the side of a cliff i've taken a
reference image straight off instagram i
will credit them as we walk through this
design today but basically i wanted to
showcase exactly how you can model a
steep site mesh and then build your
impressive castle on top of it so in
today's design we're going to be using
the australian select template feel free
to use whatever template is available to
you this is just the basic example to
make sure there's no trickery no fancy
plugins it is the bare essentials that
you have available to you in arcade 25
so straight off the bat we're going to
be starting with our foundations and
because we're going to be creating this
design over here which to me is on the
left screen but for you it's probably
either going to be above or below me
just for a continuous reference
throughout the actual tutorial looking
at this design to me it seems like there
is a three metre first floor a three
meter second floor and then potentially
about a six meter drop over something
like 20 meters
so we're going to start by pressing ctrl
and 7 or command and 7 depending on what
type of system you're on in this design
our first floor is actually our ground
floor and we're working our way down so
instead of going upwards we're going to
go down in this situation so let's
delete the roof story and delete the
first floor now we're just simply going
to start with our ground floor next
we're going to go insert below i'm going
to make that only about 300 millimeters
because you don't need too much in there
i'm going to insert one more below i'm
going to call that just straight
basement and that will be three meters
to the next floor so then we have our
3.3 below our ground floor i'm simply
going to insert another one above that
and call that ground ceiling and again
just make that 300 millimeters so that
everybody is on the same page we have a
ground ceiling we have our basement
ceiling and we're working our way down
so clicking okay we can exit out of that
and yes we can delete those stories
which you'll see rapidly changed over
here so we can actually continue working
on what we're designing today the main
focus is really going to be on the side
itself and then we're going to work
towards a quick replication of this
building here we're not really going to
focus too much on the actual design
we're just going to replicate it very
quickly at the end if you want to know
more about the building feel free to
jump along it is stamped in the
timestamp so starting with our mesh
straight away we have our mesh site i'm
going to draw a simple box and all my
layers appear to be correct so let's
start at the intersection of zero zero
zero on archicad let's draw a relatively
big square so we know what we are
working with so if i press the tab key
it's going to activate my dimensions and
let's say we want to have that at 50
meters wide and we probably want to have
that at about or 60 meters long so we
have a nice rectangle starting straight
away what you'll see is i've mistakenly
made that on the basement layer so i'm
going to press ctrl c
delete that by tapping the delete key
come across to our ground floor plan and
paste that back in there with ctrl v
finally i'm just going to tap off that
come into 3d to showcase what we've
created so at the start we've created
nothing but a flat box
and we're going to continue to basically
emphasize these steep hill on the left
so if i click on this mesh i'm going to
simply make it 30 meters
deep so that way i can actually start
cutting down the side of the hill
basically looking at it from a very
simple point of view if i take this fill
tool just to be able to actually create
some shapes and some general ideas of
where things belong let's say we have
our long emphasized shape here we'll
make it 30 meters by 10 meters that
seems about right and then by holding
the alt key clicking on that again we
can draw our secondary square which is
probably about there they look exactly
the same length so let's go 10 meters by
another 30 meters which in all honesty
is probably a bit of an overkill so i'm
going to tap on that edge drag it back
let's drag it back 10 meters roughly
here
is where the edge of those retaining
walls is on that image so basically what
we're going to be creating is a stepping
site from this point here going further
and further and further down now like i
said before it looks approximately like
three meters on the ground floor three
meters in the basement
and then another six meters to the
bottom of this retaining wall maybe a
little bit where we see the edge of the
photo so that means it's a 12 meter drop
from the top of the house to the bottom
if we lose that three meters of the
basement probably about a nine meter
fall so if we do some simple maths by
pressing the m key we get our measuring
tool we can search that it's 30 meters
approximately from the edge of where
i've started my mesh to the line that
i've drawn so now if we open up our
calculator tool we can simply go 30
meters divided by 9 meters and you'll
see we get a 3.33 recurring
contour line now i do want to make these
a little bit undulating and a bit
challenging and not just a steep drop so
what we're going to do is we're going to
select our spline tool and i'm simply
just going to click anywhere and draw my
first curve so that's going to be my
first curve holding the alt button again
i'm going to draw my second curve now by
pressing ctrl d i can move this across
control d again i'm going to make sure
that is 3 3 3 3
minus button and then enter which makes
it exactly three meters 333 millimeters
away from that original line i'm going
to repeat that process a couple more
times until i get to this edge and i'm
going to show you what the finished
product looks like of just these simple
2d spline lines okay and there we have
most of those spline lines created just
basically freehand clicking and
sketching wherever we want what i do
want to just simply do is make sure none
of my lines are overlapping the previous
line that we drew so if i fix that one
up everything should be relatively
perfect now what we want to come in and
do is select our mesh tool go to our
mesh hold the space bar over that spline
line that we drew and click on it and
then while still holding the space bar
click on that line and select okay you
want to repeat that same step for the
rest of these spline lines now that we
have all those points created we can
simply select all those splines delete
them
again delete that spline there and then
start manipulating this entire surface
here so if we click on that mesh again
and let's pick our first corner which is
going to be a dead flat line across the
front we're going to click on this
corner and then we're going to come
across this elevate mesh point which
looks like a line with a z on it so
clicking on that i'm going to change
that
to project zero and that is going to be
project zero zero so basically for me
that is the top of my boundary that is
my ground floor of where i enter which
is zero zero i'm going to click ok on
that line now because i made nine
identical lines that ended roughly at
the edge of this building i'm going to
lower them by one meter each so if i
click on this line line that i created
and then once again click on
that point there it's automatically
going to jump back to our mesh
adjustment so we don't have to keep
fiddling around with that which is
really good then i'm going to come
across to here project zero apply to all
which means it's going to apply to all
of these little dots here minus one
meter clicking okay next i'm going to
repeat that step on the next spline
again minus two meters so every single
line we're dropping one meter further so
if i continue that pattern all the way
down let's go three meters and then
we're going to go minus
four meters and i'm going to continue
that pattern all the way down till we
get to the end of our sight mesh now
that i've got minus 11 on this final
line i'm simply going to go to this
corner here and go minus 12 meters
and minus 12 meters on that corner as
well
if we come back into our 3d we'll see
that our site has completely changed and
there's two simple errors in our mesh
here which we can simply click on the
edge and align with the nearest points
to it and there we go now we have our
sloping mesh site that replicates what
we see roughly on this diagram over here
i quickly want to point out if you are
an architecture student or somebody in
the architecture profession the first
link down in the description below will
take you directly to my website where
you can download a series of
construction drawing checklists and even
sketch design checklists these are
fundamental for anybody starting out
that wants to make sure they have
everything on their plans every single
time i still use these checklists every
single day to make sure that any
document that leaves the office is 100
perfect so if you do need some
assistance with your construction
drawings or even your sketch design
plans that are going out to clients and
you're trying to impress make sure you
check out those checklists now that we
have our contours created we can start
modeling and manipulating this house
over here so we've got the foundational
building blocks of what we're going to
be creating i'm simply going to click on
all of these elevation and section
markers ctrl d and just move them out of
the way because we don't need that for
now what we do want to be creating is a
nice big thick slab on both the roof the
ground and everything in between so we
can actually mimic this building but
let's start by simply replicating the
actual perimeter walls so if we start
with our wall tool wall external we'll
just change that to a 90 millimeter stud
partition because it's predominantly
glass
what we can see is the back of this
building on the ground floor plan
runs all the way across the perimeter by
tapping the p button it'll flip that
wall the way we want it to go then i'd
assume this wrap around corner goes
about three meters so i'm going to hold
the shift button and press the d key
that i can type in three meters again
shift d
let's go back one meter
and then i'm gonna again hold shift come
all the way to the edge of this i think
that's sitting back in
approximately two meters so what i'm
going to do is press that d button again
go two meters and then tap the minus key
so it's automatically doing the maths
for me two meters away for the purpose
of this seven minus two is very simply
five but it's more so about teaching you
those shortcuts now i can't see the rest
of this photo so i'm literally just
gonna assume that it runs all the way
back there and ties into that first wall
that we drew if we come into 3d to see
what we've drawn so far you can see that
we've started to draw the basic elements
of this house now if we come back to our
ground floor plan i am going to take the
slab tool go to my generic slab i'm
going to make a
250 millimeter suspended concrete with
timber finish then i'm going to press
control up
right click on my ground floor show as
trace reference simply duplicate that
space there ctrl down down once again
duplicate that entire roof section there
and if i tap escape key go back to my 3d
we're going to see that we've started to
create what we're looking at in the
image now the basement i do want to
click on that once go control d and lift
that to our ground setting and then i'm
going to start mimicking my actual
materials whilst we go through this
process so this already has a timber
floor this is upside down so if we go
ctrl t
i'm simply just going to change that to
a generic concrete structure so changing
that to concrete and then all three
materials actually aren't concrete we're
just going to simply make them a
nice black color i'm going to click ok
reopen those settings by pressing
command t so i don't have to go through
all of them
and change the bottom of our wood to
wood walnut horizontal so
now if we look at our actual design it's
starting to look very similar to what we
see in the picture i'm then going to
click on my base concrete floor
control t open up those settings replace
them all with the same black color we
selected ok control t
unlink and change the top to
a walnut horizontal again so now we have
the black edge of that concrete slab we
have the black roof we have this
concrete section over here that we need
to manipulate so if i click on that all
those walls were linked as one by
pressing alt and g we're going to be
able to unlink those so selecting those
two walls ctrl t adjusting just the
outside layer to some sort of concrete
let's make it concrete light 23 for the
time being and press ok now we have the
first floating section of our building
we're going to come back into our ground
floor plan and we're simply going to
start adding some windows so coming into
our palette on the left hand side let's
go window open up the window settings
either there or by pressing command t
and then personally i believe the
easiest way to do it here is to just
simply go okay drop it into our project
where it needs to be go to 3d and scale
it as we see fit so that first window as
you can see basically spans the whole
way of that entire perimeter wall we're
just simply dragging it all the way up
it is a full height
extremely extremely large panel of glass
and looking at that it's probably half
the size of that so what i've done is
maybe overkilled the depth of that
building so instead of reducing
everything i'm simply going to reduce
that window here one meter and make it
four meters in total then control d
allows us to move that wall one meter
holding the shift button i can select
all three of those walls control i
joins all three of those walls together
and then we can continue to replicate
what we need around the side of the
house coming back into our ground floor
plan let's open up these window settings
here by going ctrl t and we're basically
going to click our way through until we
get to the corner sash settings next we
want to click the custom corner one 90
degrees click ok and we'll see we've
created this corner over here we simply
want to drag that back to the edge
hold our alt button and replicate that
window on this side so as you can see it
isn't the right section so we're going
to use one of our three starting nodes
over here
clicking it where it needs to be pushing
it back the other way then going back
into 3d to see what we've created i'm
going to simply click on both of these
windows now control t
open up these floor settings and
overwrite everything with a black pen
because i can't stand that orange
personally next i'm going to drop down
my basic menu go to my model attributes
and change all of those window frames to
a nice gloss black clicking okay you'll
see that drastic change between the two
i do need a mullion transition in this
window so ctrl t allows us to open up
the settings again going to sash options
changing our hv grid going to our front
view vertical one horizontal two
gives us that single one in the middle
it looks like a very thick commercial
frame so we're going to go 100mm 100mm
clicking ok gives us that look that we
are looking for now it looks like it
repeats a very simple pattern of two
panels one large panel two panels one
large panel for the rest of the house so
what i'm going to do is come back into
my ground floor plan hold my alt key and
click on that window
replicating it over here going into the
settings command t
coming down to our corner settings
unticking my custom corner 1 because
it's no longer required control or
command d and then bring it back in line
with that other window i do again want
to go ctrl d tapping the control button
a secondary time and aligning it third
time on the edge so if we come back into
our 3d window we'll see we've created a
repetition of the same window clicking
into this middle window control t opens
our settings once more scrolling up sash
options no grid okay and there you have
that first little look that we see on
top the big panel the two panels the big
panel the two panels and in our ground
floor now we can simply repeat that
pattern by clicking on this window here
holding the shift button and clicking on
that secondary window by tapping control
d and then control and alt at the same
time we can duplicate that multiple
times to the edge of that building
coming back into 3d you'll see that
we've replicated that pattern of 2 1 2 1
all the way down and because i can't see
what's happening on the edge of that
building i'm not really too fast now if
we go back to our ground floor plan and
hold the alt button i can duplicate the
settings of that wall going control down
down brings us to our basement level
as we can see our basement level does
actually replicate above of what's
happening there and then it appears to
go back in another maybe two meters over
that so if we type in 5 meters back
there
we can once again hold shift go to the
top tap d
go 2 meters minus enter run our wall all
the way back
run it all the way in
and again because i can't see what's
happening on the other side i would
assume it would repeat a similar pattern
like that does there if we come into our
3d we'll see that we've started to
create the foundation of that secondary
floor again it looks way way way too big
again i'm going to come into my basement
floor plan go ctrl d and i'm going to
move this wall back another five meters
holding the control button i can click
on my additional walls and basically
just cut them right off that definitely
looks a little bit better than what we
were previously looking at and it's
starting to look like we are creating
the same shapes as what is seen up here
now we are missing the roof of this
basement floor plan so if we go to our
ground ceiling and tap control minus
once so if we tap our alt button we can
duplicate the settings of that slab
right click basement show as trace
reference and then we can basically
assume that our roof does that go back
into 3d just to double check on the
actual roof we've created control d
let's just drag that and the entire
ground floor down
300 millimeters as that is exactly what
it does
over on this diagram we're then simply
going to drag and extend our entire roof
plan
all the way to the back over here and
alt g ungroups all of our walls by
lifting them to the ground floor we can
actually finish off what they've created
as an intersection point over here now
we'll point out that the story settings
aren't 100 correct on this situation we
really would have to go into it a little
bit deeper but the fundamental basics
are there to actually understand what
we're trying to create now we'll also
note that the basement ceiling does
extend two meters so just like we did a
second ago we're gonna click on that
blue line
and extend it two meters here extend
that two meters there so we're starting
to get that foundation of this building
stacked on top of another building
coming back into our basement plan i do
want to extend this wall an additional
two meters so by holding shift and
pressing the d key we can type in two
meters that appears to be plasterboard
all the way through in that image so we
don't even have to cut that wall to be
able to actually give it a second
texture but what we do need to do is
press control up click on that slab
we've created control c control down
control down
we don't have a basement floor so i'm
just going to do a footings layer that
is minus 300 below and click ok and then
ctrl v and click off so we create our
actual ground floor element that ties
back into our actual boundary walls now
what we do have is again a series of
glass panels on that basement so if we
come back to our ground floor scroll up
scroll into our large panel of glass
click the alt button and click on that
window control down control down
we can start basically creating those
windows all the way from here so if i
wanted to just simply replicate them all
the way around we could do that simply
repeating the same process until we make
it all the way around coming into 3d
we'll see that we need to lift our
actual slab to the proper basement
height so that it aligns perfectly as we
wanted it now obviously this is
incorrect we do want to basically just
change that to black
and change the underneath to wood so
that we repeat the same look that we
have above over here what you will
notice is now that we need a retaining
wall basically cutting right into that
panel of glass and wrapping back around
this house to basically create some sort
of planter so we're going to come into
our basement floor plan i'm going to
select my wall tool and i'm going to
select a nice big chunky brick wall so
let's go block work of 270 millimeters
and then i'm gonna start at the edge
here go one meter out hold the shift key
go one meter past that so five meters
maybe let's go six meters actually and
then return back into our window over
here if i come into 3d you'll see that
they are way way too high and linked to
that top floor so alt g will connect all
of those control t will open up the
settings and then we don't want to link
that and it appears that it's only about
1200 height so we'll click ok
and you'll see that we're starting to
actually replicate what's seen in this
photo now before we leave this section i
do want to change all of those settings
so ctrl t to open up the settings
overwrite all of them at once and let's
select a nice stone so let's go
stonework 12 for the time being and
click ok you'll see some nice big chunky
stone right there and then we're going
to come into our basement alt on that
section there of that wall control down
to our footings layer and what we are
seeing is basically that retaining wall
all the way around the edge of this
building i'd assume it wraps all the way
back over here as well but that is a
little bit unknown because we don't see
it
coming back into 3d we'll see that we've
drawn our basement wall control d allows
us to move it down to where it needs to
go
i'm going to continue extending that
wall much much further alt g allows us
to ungroup which then allows us to
basically drag it out i'm going to
extend that another three meters and
then all of these contour lines aren't
dropping fast enough in my opinion so
we're going to come back to our actual
ground story and we're going to start
adjusting them so they drop
significantly quicker so this line over
here if we click on one of those nodes
and edit the mesh it's at about three
meters so let's drop that to four and
then continue to drop this two meters at
a time so this is going to be minus 6
minus 8 minus 10 minus 12 and i'm going
to repeat that till we get to the bottom
now that bottom line is minus 20 so i'm
going to make both of these minus 22 so
that it continues to fall away instead
of coming all the way up coming back
into our 3d to make sure we've done that
correctly absolutely we've just got
these little errors on the side like we
had before so i'm just simply going to
drag and drop them to adjust them to
roughly where i think they need to be
they're not overly critical but you'll
see we've now mastered that drop
significantly better than what we had
before so once again let's come into our
footings layer and we're then basically
going to continue these additional
planter boxes around the edge of the
bottom of the building so if we take
that approximately somewhere in the
middle of that wall let's go out one
meter
wrap around past that one meter further
and wrap into the edge and then finally
we're going to repeat that same step p
to flip the wall
all the way out to the edge all the way
back it looks like that just continues
to go and go and go so i'd assume that
basically snow is covering the entirety
of that retaining wall clicking it to
the edge
showing in 3d to see what we've created
and alt g allows us basically to create
what we need ctrl t
not linked we only want to make that
about two meters tall control d let's
drag that to the base so if you see
these bottom lines go from
solid to dashed so if we're looking at
the right side where it intersects with
the mesh it slowly goes dash the further
we drop it down so if i know that it's
dashed it's hidden below all of that
mesh
secondly i can do the same thing with
the retaining wall that's slightly above
it that retaining wall only looks about
a meter high it doesn't look as drastic
as the last one i do want to simply drop
it just to where it needs to be and then
i'm going to alt g ungroup and extend
that all the way down so now we have
that sheer drop off of building very
elegant very dramatic on the edge of a
cliff there isn't too much more to this
tutorial guys it is relatively simple it
was just the fundamental building blocks
of what we need to do to create
something on an incredibly steep site
there is a numerous amount of
architectural details engineering
consideration that would go into
something like this but that video would
take months and months and months to
explain so this is more so a fundamental
basic guide of how you can create this
mesh and then simply model something
just as steep and just as beautiful on
that block anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video i
hope you learned something today and i
hope you can apply it to the real world
if you have noticed i have been posting
a ton of shorts lately and only one of
them has started to take off because the
youtube algorithm is a complete guess to
me when it comes to shorts but i thought
hey let's get on the bandwagon let's
start creating some shorts and let's
pump out some high quality content so
you guys can learn more do more and
achieve more every single day but like i
said that is absolutely all for me so
like always i'll see you next monday